hey guys and welcome back to let's play
roller coaster [ __ ] 3 I know I haven't
actually made a video of this series in
a long time and I've actually not
recorded a video of this series in a
longer time than it seems in YouTube
it's been way over a month and I know
this is most likely something which I've
already referred to in comments but
never really very clearly explained in a
video which is basically I don't want to
work on this pike if I just don't feel
like it and if I just don't have any
inspiration it doesn't necessarily mean
that I am bored with roller coaster core
three years again how I've played plenty
of rollercoaster go three lately I just
felt very much stuck on this park and I
wanted to not do what I did with rose
gardens where I really felt like I had
to make videos of it and in the end I'm
actually not happier with that Park
hence why almost a year after it's
pretty much done there still isn't a
final video of rose gardens and I don't
know if there ever will be one and I
just want to make sure that I do still
keep this entire park on track and I'm
just happy about whenever I build so
whenever I don't really just feel like
playing the game just don't have the
inspiration for it or not in the mood
for it I just don't work on this park
but yeah I did do some other stuff and
there's definitely some projects that
you'll see in the future but what I
should probably say about this let's
play Park is that I do want to get back
into the full swing of things and what I
feel sort of halted me was coming to
finalize the English area of the park
which is something that I sort of didn't
really look forward to doing and another
issues the dark ride which I just don't
have experience for so I'm really just
procrastinating that out of the good
reason that I just don't have enough
dark ride experience just a limited
amount of rights that no I've never even
released because I wasn't happy about
them so that's something which I do want
to work on later on and for now I'll
just leave it behind and work on the
next area and some small things I did
want to change a couple of things in the
English area as well since I did receive
some comments and looking back at the
area really felt that there were some
things I wanted to change one of them
was that the queue line was pretty much
non-existent outside of the building and
there were many people who actually gave
me that
to get gopher and more revenge of the
mummy style approach when you sort of
have the cue swinging back and forth in
front of the entrance of the building
and I felt like that was a really cool
thing to try to still have that red
carpet in there Louis oh I might keep
that just for the ornamental sake of it
but I might change that if YouTube but
yeah like you should now be a little bit
nicer also I wanted to open up the area
in front of the station building I mean
in front of the darkride entrance
building just so it's a little bit more
clear to see so remove that enormous
planter and replaced it with some
smaller planters and in some time later
in this episode I'll also be adding some
very small planters with some flowers in
them just to I guess spice up the area a
little bit but also just make the entire
English area feel and less depressing
which is something I'll get to later on
in this episode as well but first I
should probably explain what the hell is
going on over here this is something
which I normally don't really want to
get into when it comes to my videos and
I don't really want to record since it's
such a weird thing but here's just a bit
of planning the park that is not
necessarily to say that I just don't
like to show it to people
it's do something which isn't really too
much part of the progress of a park and
the building but I just sort of did it
in between building stuff over here and
I figured it's also quite important
because this will really shape and the
park is gonna end up looking in the end
well basically I had the entire general
idea of what I wanted to have the park
layout be like in my head for all this
time and really felt like I needed to
also just jot it down on the park file
and make sure that I got everything to
look like the way I wanted it and to
look at my plans again and my ideas and
decide whether I actually wanted to do
it like that so a bit of explanation
about what's actually going on with all
these terraforming things the squares
with the breaks around them are welcome
I obviously planned buildings and every
little zone as their own pre proposed
color so for instance this
very green yellowish grass is going to
be Germany and the very dark reddish
brown is going to be Austria and that's
how that's gonna work the very light
brown are going to be the paths and the
gray is going to be some sort of a
mountain shape with rocks where I do
want to have a most likely mind train in
the future at least that's what I've
been planning for that area all this
time that's the general overall plan for
that area in terms of theme
I wanna eventually oh god I think
actually in the real-time footage I said
that I wouldn't say too much about the
theme but um about the theme it's gonna
be a German theme around this area but
German is a very very wide thing there
many different variations within that
and which I would like to play a bit
with different styles as well but in
general I do not follow a Bavarian type
architecture partly because I like the
style but also because you see some
stucco elements in there which very
neatly fits I think with the mock tudor
woodwork that you see in England which I
have in the English area but also the
woodwork which you see in Austria so I
feel like the Bavarians type of building
can be the best sort of transition from
England to Austria and fit within both
areas and hopefully the synergy between
the German and the Austrian buildings
will be good in the end as well yeah the
plan is I have that mountain over there
in the corner there is that green space
in between the mountain and the paths
where I do have a small river running
just because I figured it'd look cool
and that's pretty much the plan
no entire plan as of yet of how the
culture is gonna run or what type of
extra flat ride I'm gonna add but that's
a general sort of plan with which I want
to attack the area thing is I am not too
big of a fan of planning but it's just
something which especially in retrospect
of the areas which I have right now is
something that I I really feel like I
need to do it's kind of like that too
much structure is not good for you
versus to do less structure is also not
good for you like in a way I
wanna plan because I felt like in
hindsight the English area and the
Spanish area aren't planned enough so
they sort of turned into a chaos but
then again I also don't want to restrict
myself too much to a pretty given plan
and it's always more fun and more
creative to just step out of that and do
whatever you want to do so yeah it's
just a general sort of vague plan but it
doesn't entirely resemble what I'm gonna
do 100% in the end but it is something
that I generally want to follow just to
make sure that before I start building
things I think all the dimensions and
the entire idea behind the area is right
see yeah that's pretty much the entire
planning aspect I just wanted to add a
couple of details to the Parliament /
City Hall building over here since I
thought it was very one of the reasons
why I felt the building was so gray and
dull and depressing is because it even
though it has so many details they were
all in the same color so I wanted to add
a bit more contrast in there and
actually at the white pillows but also
some dark brown accents and this is
actually very funny another thing which
I figured in the end sort of made
England look so depressing misses it
this is something that I talked about in
one of the earlier episodes where I said
that I felt like the English area was
looking so depressing and I should add
more foliage to it but then again I
already have so much foliage and what
can I do and England is depressing
anyway and then I got some angry
Englishmen but in the end what I really
felt was one of the key issues over
there actually was that my brightness
was turned down all the way to very low
so brightness is a bit higher right now
and with that I think it actually
already looks much more alive and much
more vibrant which really helps and
there will be also a bit more foliage
like obviously some of the poplars over
there and the flowers also helped to
make the area look a little less dull
and rainy and gray and English in
general anyway that's that's about the
the depressing look of the English area
which should be a little bit better by
now but something I still do want to
change in the future because obviously
the path elements like lamps benches
planters orange completely done
in the English area not to mention that
I still want to have some of those
things that really make an area feel
alive like small stores and vendor carts
and signs and stuff like that still
something that I want to add anyway at
this point in the video
I should have long started talking about
these two towers over here which I
haven't done so far I'll explain a bit
in the real time part about it as well
but basically since this is right on the
border between the English and the
German area I wanted to make sure to
have some sort of good transition
just like the function was the bridge
between the Netherlands and Spain in
this case and the railroad crossing
between the Netherlands and England but
the issue over here I felt was that if I
didn't put something that sort of
blocked the view in between England and
Germany you could see the mountain from
England which would look awfully off an
Alpine and on the other hand you could
see the English coaster and all of the
English gardens from Germany which would
also be Willard so I figured the best
sort of attack would be to just put a
building as a sort of transition between
both areas and also in a way block the
view from one area to the other without
being too obviously a blockade of
blocking the view and really felt that a
castle was the best way to go about
doing so and especially an English
castle since here's the thing and this
is some of that I'll return them and
I'll return to in the real time part as
well but English castles do typically
not have fancy spires in a way that many
German or Alpine castles would have that
but much more decorated with battlements
and I really felt like I could have
towers with battlements realistically in
a German town you can't have towers with
many decorations and a real fantasy
theme to it in an English town so it
really felt like the best choice to get
a castle wall over here that resembles
the English castles rather than the
German councils and eventually just put
some birches on the German side to make
sure that you can see that there's a
castle wall the hair with some
but you can't actually see then it's
completely in English consul wall and
I'm actually quite happy about how this
turned out
it's very surprising to me actually is
that this was using some of the some of
the sets which I am by far most familiar
of of all of the accustomed scenery sets
out there being Ralphie's antique world
which I've used for such a long time and
so much and also Ralphie's medieval and
a number of other sets for the accents
of course and even though those are two
sets which I've used so commonly I've
never actually used them together but I
only now just realised how well they
actually work for an English consul and
I might just want to randomly try
building an English classroom because it
was actually a lot of fun that said this
won't be the only bit of building for
this gate over here primarily on the
right side next to the railroad over
there I do think I want to extend this
building and bits I just wanted to make
sure that I got this sort of portal into
the other zone right over a big
statements that once actually had this
transition done I could start actually
working on the German area which is
something that I really feel like I want
to do and something which I should have
moved onto so much earlier but only now
really only got two and that's pretty
much the idea behind this there's not
even any major inspiration for this just
English consuls in general but I did
want to have a bit of a decoration
underneath this tower just to make sure
it wasn't all just cold and on detailed
stone towers but also have a bit of that
woodwork and iron work as an ornamental
arch underneath it it's really just a
bit of creative freedom I suppose I took
that because it's not something that you
would realistically see but just
something which I figured would look
pretty good I'm also pretty sure I
forgot a window on the back side over
there yep yeah I'll go back to that in
the future there's a number of things I
still want to add to this like
eventually definitely want to make the
foliage on the sides move toward the
castle towers a bit more to make sure
they blend into the environment a bit
more perhaps even add some like
overgrowth to it like
vines just creeping up the walls that
would be really cool but then again this
is all still quite a big
work-in-progress
I just wanted to make sure that I got
this in here sort of a step forward and
closing the chapter of England and
actually moving on for a change and
actually getting going here again and
that's the entire idea behind this which
also means that some of the detailing
definitely not going too much into
detail there just spam the put a couple
of boxes and crates just to make sure
that I got that in there but I'll
definitely be adding more ornaments
around this entire area in general
anyway that's it for the time lapse part
for today I'll jump to a small real time
point now so I'll pass it over to my
past self alright so I just recorded one
major section over here without actually
recording and also it's pretty late at
night so it might sound a bit sleepy and
tired at the moment but yeah his the
current state of things didn't really
add too much over here I just wanted to
make sure I got some sort of transition
going because the main issue is I've
probably by now also said in the
commentary over the time-lapse is that I
was really stuck for a couple weeks over
here and just wanted to transition into
the Alpine area and figure out the best
way to do that always with a simple set
of towers I didn't want to just leave it
empty since you could you would be
clearly able to see the other buildings
on the other side and it wouldn't be too
smooth a transition I figured especially
given how not so much space there is
over here and so these towers are sort
of I feel like an in-between solution
and the thing is I didn't want to have
towers with fancy spires or colorful
materials since I really wanted to make
sure that from the English area it
looked like a decently English castle
and traditionally English castles have
more of this type of material use but
also don't actually have spires with
fancy roofs and decorations but rather
battlements and I figured going with the
English style and dressing it up that
way could prove as a good sort of facade
and transition from the english area
into the alpine area but the reverse
reverse should also be fine with some
buildings over here and stuff like that
and that's basically what the function
of this pretty simple building is I do
still want to work on this area bits add
some part elements and make it feel bit
more alive than it currently does and of
course this is also something where I'm
gonna want to add a bit of castle II
stuff to this thing anyway in the next
episode slash next episodes and I don't
know why I can't use the advanced camera
all of a sudden I'm gonna want to work
on the Alpine area because that's
something I really kind of want to do
and I have some plans and ideas on how
I'm gonna do that exactly but you'll see
that eventually I won't bore you with
that anyway thank you guys for watching
this episode and see you guys later